en tout cas la hausse des prix de
l'énergie profitent aux pétrolière
suncor a dégagé des profits nets de 2
milliards neuf cent cinquante millions
de dollars à son premier trimestre c'est
trois fois plus qu'à la même période
l'an dernier les revenus ont grimpé à 13
milliards 500 millions une hausse de 57%
le pdg de suncor marque les tôles a
déclaré que l'entreprise n'est pas
intéressé à vendre sa chaîne de
stations-service petro-canada
malgré la pression de certains
investisseurs activistes son corps va
verser un dividende trimestriel de 47
cents par action ordinaire aux
actionnaires avec nous ce soir carol
montreuil vice président à l'association
canadienne du carburant on sort monsieur
montreuil
est ce qu'on peut dire que les
pétrolières carbure au profit ses jeux
ses jours ci
en fait vous avez une bonne introduction
succès c'est une prise historique on
manque de qualificatifs maintenant pour
tenter d'expliquer la situation qui pose
juste qui vais pas aux canadiennes les
médias tous les continents ont le même
problème est présent un parce que cette
crise là qui on le sait est attribuable
aux conflits en ukraine
ceci étant dit effectivement avec une
matière première de pétrole brut qui ont
explosé en vol ar en valeur si vous êtes
quelqu'un qui en produisent et
effectivement ce marché mondial va vous
donner des profits extrêmement
intéressant et les gens qui sont dans
cette partie de l'industrie sadi qui est
alors malheureusement dans le privé mais
ceux qui le font à libertas ce qui le
fonde en argentique pour l'instant cette
semaine avec des prix suivie sur la
scène mondiale on a l'impression que
ceux qui ne passent pas à la caisse ou
en tout cas ceux qui doivent payer cher
en ce moment ce sont
les automobilistes quand on compare le
prix du litre d'essence aujourd'hui avec
la moyenne des 52 dernières semaines on
voit que le coût d'acquisition quand
même fortement augmenté il est passé de
95 à 100 38 cents ça c'est pour montréal
aujourd'hui il ya des taxes qui sont
fixes d'autres qui sont variables mais
dans tous les cas elles sont à la hausse
et la marge de détail a augmenté de
presque 25% aujourd'hui on est à 9,4
cents sur ce litre pourquoi la marge de
détail augmente quand ça en fait si on
regarde la lymphe la marge au détail et
peu importe le marché ce million période
c'est une très petite partie de ce que
représente le prix vous dit votre table
ou le montrait la marge de détail qui
toujours doux de 8,9 sous son contrôle
des prix à deux de leurs raisonnements
et c'est ce qui marche peut être un
détail à la régie de disait dernièrement
un détaillant ce plan de 2 à 2,2 me un
détail en fait à la prendre donc c'est
pas ça qui est attribuable aux hausses
spectaculaires on vu depuis quelques
mois on le sait l'an passé c'était un de
leurs parents on est à deux gardes chez
elle c'est encore pire on était un
médecin pour l'an passé et cette année à
2h50 c'est une augmentation de 100 % 6
ya quelques mois la crise elle est
d'importance où tous les marchés et
surtout attribuable à la matière
première est revu et augmenté de façon
importante c'est vrai que le pétrole
brut augmentait de façon importante et
que c'est l'élément principal mais on a
l'impression qu'à tous les niveaux on
carbure davantage aux profils plus hauts
revenus si vous me permettez
l'expression
mais que le consommateur au bout du
compte lui doit tout simplement accepté
de payer davantage est-ce que ce prix de
l'essence à plus de 2 dollars le litre
selon vos projections c'est le prix
qu'on va payer cet été en vacances et en
fait vous leviez canton dès qu'on pose
de grilles à la pop oubliez que jusqu'à
six axes différents à la pompe à
montréal dont 6,6 taxe 500 à rennes en
pourcentage qui remet en également avec
le prix à la pompe donc pour nous
d'étudier la boule de cristal magique
personne de la personne je croirais
personnes qui s'aventuraient à une
prédiction parce que d'un pourtour est
le conflit qui continue à une pression à
la hausse sur les prix mais devant audi
vous le savez vous êtes le spécialiste
on parle de plus en plus du mot en r
fameuse récession qui ralentirait
l'économie qui ralentirait la demande
pour les produits pétroliers et nord
aurait un effet à la baisse sur les prix
donc laquelle des deux thèses vont
l'emporter le conflit qui mesure où
arras l'économie faute de l'avoir mais
pour l'instant très hasardeux de prédire
où c'est le il ya quand même des gens
qui font des projections un embargo sur
le pétrole russe ferait passer le prix
du baril de pétrole de 100 à 180 5
dollars le baril selon jp morgan à 170
dollars selon la banque centrale
d'allemagne est ce que ça veut dire ça
deux dollars 50 le litre d'essence est
ce que ça fait partie des possibilités
vous y verrez vous soulevez très bon
point on utilise du pouce à
approximativement 1 dollars le baril un
sou à la pompe ça tient à peu près donc
imaginé une augmentation de 60 70
dollars eux qui voudraient une
augmentation de 60 70 sous le litre
selon une prévision de 10 points au lieu
de mars dernier si effectivement
l'ensemble du buzz bus était bloqué pour
une telle sanction ding dong remplacer
quatre millions de baril par jour sur la
planète c'est énorme
edit on prévoit que si l'extension et
des piastres est bloqué à 100% ce 4
million baril par jour là les prix
pourraient augmenter jusqu'à 185 heures
quand nous disiez plus 60 dollars donc
plus de 60 soupe alors aujourd'hui on
dépasserait allègrement de la source de
profits pour les pétrolières
à suivre de ce côté là également
oui exactement une famille qui veut
faire on a fait quelques d'aujourd'hui
que veut faire le tour de la gaspésie
avec un véhicule utilitaire sport de
10,7 litres le 100 km par de montréal
ces 150 dollars de plus en essence par
rapport à la même période l'an passé
c'est quand même une pression importante
pour les clients vos clients des
pétrolières et des stations service ce
gression énorme et il a su me nous qui
l'avons choisi ce conflit là il est
comme disait mondiale elle a fait le
budget de transfert d'une famille
moyenne qui va voyager fait partie dans
le budget global de hb inclus
effectivement la nourriture des hôtels
des activités et donc les gens vont
peut-être choisir de se déplacer un peu
moins loin et gens vont coûter de
choisir de faire un peu moins de
distance de façon générale pour quand
même prend des vacances mais en fait
c'est quelque chose où à travers mes
pavani sa cavale du pays du globe on a à
peu près aucun contrôle jusqu'à temps
que jusqu'à ce que je veux ou fils à ce
réseau vous l'avez pas choisi vous avez
pas de contrôle mais en entendant les
profits de son corps par exemple
aujourd'hui ont triplé et les revenus
ont augmenté de 57 pour ça donc ce sont
les pétrolières qui sans mettre
davantage dans les poches dans les
circonstances mais pour toutes les
compagnies qui explique que si la même
chose l'ensemble de l'industrie qu'on
appelle en allemand malheureusement le
pot québec ces gens là se font offrir
maintenant un sens disparaît de la
quitter à 25 ans 69 ans et 6 mois
offensivement pour ça c'est une manne
tombée du ciel merci monsieur montaut et
d'avoir été avec nous j'aurais plaisir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici r d